yeah and then I got that at 20 so that I
mean obviously that's a life changer
yeah that changed everything
I wasn't Aeneas when did you meet your
wife which one you were married twice
yeah I was married once before this the
four kids that you have now are they
working with my current wife the current
mrs. Van der P oh wow so when was the
first one who did you marry the first
time I married a great girl I mean I
know she's great she's great she's great
what didn't work out man it's just it
just really didn't some things just
don't work out all right I was young she
was young and like you kind of machine
actress yeah famous I don't want to know
what it is but no famous okay I mean not
famous just good really good yeah she's
good um really good and then um
but yeah it just didn't work as a
marriage we were best friends and were
like this and then it was like oh wait
by the time we finally realized like
wait a minute
maybe doesn't doesn't have to be a
marriage like oh wow we could be friends
now thank God so is it was um was it in
your 20s I'm sorry yeah you don't have
to answer if you don't want to but
because you know you want just let me
out all right yeah you're on Dawson's
Creek you're married right but did you
ever go on a [ __ ] frenzy you seem like
a guy that wouldn't go on a [ __ ] frenzy
I just no not really I mean listen when
I was single
yeah that's what I'm 30 I between your
marriages did you go on a [ __ ] frenzy
I mean not if I would call it a frenzy
it's a friendiy what can you explain
what a frenzy looks like a job Chris
D'Elia he goes on Pauly Shore they go on
frenzy frenzy multiple in one day
sometimes three in one day yeah
you don't seem like somebody that would
go on a horsey frenzy but I need to ask
you because here's what it is you're
good-looking you're famous you're a
talented guy and I was because here's
what it is
yeah here's what it is this dude right
has every ability to go on them the most
massive [ __ ] frenzy yeah that you'll
never get my friend lipless [ __ ] you'll
never get it and you Pig [ __ ]
you'll never get either you don't have
the eyes for it let's go right here
right he had the opportunity and it's
like this it's like Wolverine not using
his claws ever Oh restraint yeah he was
restraint 'full is our word okay so you
never went out of [ __ ] friends no no I
but I don't know that that makes me a
good person I had died just it's kind of
the way I'm built but especially at the
time I was like by the time I was single
I was like a fully domesticated male
like I was a shitty dater because all I
know how to do is be married so I'd be
like so how was your day I knew how to
be married to somebody I didn't know how
to like this guy's the exact opposite i
Stan what doesn't know Hal okay what I'm
saying is this though right us is is
that you were it's in your upbringing
you were born that way you're not so do
you get credit for it if you were born
that way no no I'm just saying that it's
like you come from the good whites there
was a lot of AB Lincoln yeah so JD you
never went on a [ __ ] frenzy right
Hamilton what basically all the founding
father the way Hamilton one of the [ __ ]
frenzy [ __ ] up you don't know right
three right I just wanna go you know
that that George Washington's wife named
her feral Tomcat after Alexander
Hamilton huh did he [ __ ] or whatever yes
true yeah all that they really yes
really weird cereal but Lincoln didn't
define his wife I don't know yeah I
don't want that
Kim do it Daniel did Kim can play
Abraham blink you can do it if you go on
you're gonna make that move he could do
it that would be the funniest thing I've
ever seen
and then I could play like his son yeah
I could play son yeah as long as you
could add them yeah
[Music]